we're at this place in society now where
apparently the media has merged it's
kind of like the way we're merging with
robots
with politics there's no separation i
mean look who the the white house press
spokesman is it's always somebody the
democrats are going to hire someone from
msnbc
the republicans are going to hire
somebody from fox that we have their our
official
places cnn was supposed to be the middle
now the new boss at cnn
i think is
said he's trying to restore that is that
possible in this partisan country that
we live in to have the one place i would
love to see that the one place where i
don't feel like i'm getting anybody's
narrative
i just feel like just give me just tell
me just tell it to me
first of all that's called your show
right i mean that's right
trying
um yeah and that's why i'm a fan of the
show
i've had a lot of time on my hands
recently so i've been able to uh
watch back episodes in the podcast which
i love because it's such a different
feel it's why i'm doing the chris cuomo
project frankly i believe people do want
an alternative i believe the majority of
people in this country are what i call
free agents they have open minds and
open hearts they're not about party yeah
they're about
respectful conversation
and you can get after you can disagree
you just don't
have to surrender to hating a person
that you don't agree with and you're
open to the idea that maybe they know
something you don't right
um or they just see the world
differently yeah that's fine yes it is i
don't think it's about middle okay
here's why i don't like middle and i
don't like independent i don't like
independent because
in america we have to be interdependent
we got to care about each other here you
can't just be out for yourself
that's why i believe in free agent as a
term instead of independent it may be a
semantic difference for some but it's
not for me the other one is
it's this toxic twosome everyone's been
forced to the fringe and to pick a team
it's like being a jets fan the jets suck
and
i am a jets fan you know they're gonna
suck
oh but look at this draft pick this is
the year you don't believe it nobody
believes it but you say it because it's
your team our politics is not supposed
to be that and i believe that there's a
great chance and we are at a time in our
history
where there is an exhaustion of being
forced to play a game that people don't
want to see played
and you
and
you've had people in this chair i've
watched them
speak to this you know most people in
this country they agree on about eighty
percent of the things you know most
people this but we never speak to them
we don't address it that way we get
forced into the game yeah and that is
the problem for the media as well my
defense of the media though is this even
though
it didn't end so well for me uh most
recently is this
you can't expect the men and women in
the media to not play a game that
everybody else is playing
you are watching because the game you
are allowing yourself to be put on teams
or in tribes or any way you want to
designate it
but they're supposed to somehow break
away from that when it's what you want
what is what resonates with you no
i think that culturally
we have to end the two-party system it's
not in the constitution it's not in the
law
president washington took most of his
farewell address to say avoid parties
and the men who will seek advantage in
them we didn't listen we need more
parties we need ranked choice voting and
we need a shame campaign on purple
states to apportion their electives i
mean and then you'll have more choice
and that's what we need
you